[Music]
you dare enter this [__] house
on a Monday you better come prepared
[__]
it's Monday [__] and you better
come prepared this little fuck-around on
Monday Monday most people coming on it's
a great weekend oh my god my friends are
so [__] oh [__] yourself that was then
this is now [__] it's a whole new set
of rules it's Monday if you ain't waking
up with the taste of blood in your
[__] mouth like a shark five feet
from the shore you [__] up you
understand me because Monday is when you
go everybody else is like still from the
weekend you [__] and go eat their
[__] lunch they don't even know
they're not even thinking right but
you're out the box like a [__]
fireman you understand me uncle Joey
here ready to throw [__] heat this
week podcast tonight at 8:00
[__] working out with uncle Joey
Wednesday at 8:00 fifth hundred episode
Wednesday in the church we got a big
[__] week a plan you understand me
the 29th of July fairly been sir sir
listen the board gala is gonna be off
the [__] chain then we're gonna get
off stage on watch the John Jones fight
who's better than [__] you you
understand me so get your [__] together
but beside all that stuff it's Monday
you're not [__] around you're writing
your goals you're tip-top Magoo you're
eating your [__] cereal you got that
Apple the protein shake you wash your
balls you cut your toenails they can't
stop you [__] young Stan you
know why cuz you uncle Joey told you
that's why but anyway enough with the
chitty-chat let's get down to why we got
together for you understand I got some
tremendous [__] refill time I got the
horse with no name it's always good to
be out in the rain in the desert you
can't remember your name cause there
ain't no one for to give you no fame you
see I'm saying
that's how we do it on a [__] Monday
the thought is dead just cuz with the
smoke a little weed doesn't mean nothing
which is fueling the mental [__]
energies in your mind to unleash upon
these [__] so there's no
rebuttals today
it all goes your way understand me I
want this well we gotta [__] you I'm
taking it today's Monday you're like Joe
Zasa today if they don't give it to you
you're gonna [__] take it the same
way I don't give a [__] jack you only
got one life [__] if you're
gonna live it like Joe Zasa without
getting you here bit don't get you here
bit because then you gotta walk around
all [__] up anyway
this weed here this this [__] that
knocked out Donna Nelson you're missing
that [__] got hit hard yesterday
he's somewhere recovering with a [__]
that bandage on looking like Steven
Seagal and that one movie when he lost
his mind and he came back with Kelly
LeBrock and [__] god I still got a
[__] anyway let's park another one
of these debt balls cuz what the [__] is
on one day without heart a Monday
without heart isn't like a [__] without
an [__] that ain't gonna work you
gotta have heart on a [__] Monday but
all the heart you got in the world
listen when I got out of prison and a
halfway houses and drug dealers booking
from you think I gave a [__] you think I
gave a [__] don't trust me you gotta lay
low for a while but you got to know when
to pop you add up and attack like the
man says you've got to take what the
[__] is he saying dogs whatever the [__]
you gotta be crazy you gotta have a real
need you gotta keep on your toes when
you're on the streets you gotta be able
to pick out the easy meat with your
[__] eyes closed if you can't do that
go hang out with your little [__]
buddies at Starbucks and talk about your
dreams in your hopes because that's all
you got his dreams and hope when I ball
you can't kick down the door wave in the
for for you know Zen
there's a dream we'll get you so far
that's great I know a thousand people
got dreams but if you're not gonna put
the engine of the nutsack behind it [__]
you and your dream your dreams gonna
fail
it's Monday [__] all hands on
deck if you ain't slinging you're
sucking you follow me and none of you
[__] kind of pacifying your mom
so anyway let's take this [__]
to the next level this week it's July
17th
if then you sucking your dick today
they're gonna suck it by the end of the
[__] month that's how it works out
because you don't give a [__] your
persistence you're the Captain Kirk of
the enterprise you understand me
Oh
I can't do that pose no more elusive
humbling for dick to fly into my mouth
like a Korean missile I'm saying anyway
without you [__] meat
I got a lot you're my family I don't
want no [__] [__] fans I'm fans I
don't have my god my fat [__] you and
your [__] fans will you Kathy Griffin
[__] fans did they stick up we
got family we watch these other back I
also want to thank Holly bars my little
[__] brother awesome warrior if you
see him on Twitter give him number love
he just spent ten days appear with
savagery started his tour in Vegas at
the Comedy Store with Steve Sam on the
whole [__] thing Rogan but that don't
matter we got people like that all the
time you got my little man
[__] okie spooky who I love with all
my heart you got more balls than most of
you [__] [__] I'm [__] Twitter
kooky spooky meal take over [__]
Austin with a knife and a toothpick you
understand me I got my girl Megan 7:15
down there and Arizona holding it down
with a [__] Indian blood she ain't
[__] around you understand me and
that's it and that's that we're a family
man we're a [__] family I mean you
guys get that in your head in the church
the church ain't no podcast the church
is a state of mind to stay the - they're
gonna suck your dick you ain't taking
[__] from no because the world don't owe
you big [__]
so let's do this [__] do this [__] today
let these [__] know who the
[__] that [__] with if not go back to
bed what are you up for it
what are you up for to waste time to
goof around with your friends and you
wake up it's because somebody's paying
it till they understand me
let's do some bowls now you know me I'm
old school
that [__] perennial og the heart of
perennial mister should i smoke
constantly
it's like granulated sugar that's what
this weed is like granulated sugar use
them just defeat cancer if you get it
get that set but anyway I love you
[__] you know I do don't forget
why is their night working out with
uncle Joey I got a bunch of ideas we
bring them up on stage and we [__]
$10 you're out of here by ten o'clock
happy you seem lee-sia everything's
[__] good but the 29th they take his
lap I don't want to hear you mow [__]
crying Philly
you [__] come on and what Joey
what anyway who gives a [__] about
anything it's you me against the world
that's the bottom line today and we're
both doing the same thing don't think
there's our Matty I'm [__] knocking
these [__] [__] that deaf
does every day somebody tries to go in
your pocket every day is I'm gonna
[__] your papi you gotta tell them
listen put your head in there again I'll
put a mousetrap in out [__] you up or
I'll cut the pocket off and next time
you put your hand on my pocket is gonna
feel a [__] Cuban bacon
I'm on fire today and I hope you are the
same because this is the type I had a
dude that gets you out of that position
that position of feeling like [__] I got
sick and tired of feel my ship at 27
[__] years I felt like [__] because
that wasn't doing what I'm doing do what
you're supposed to do and this is a
[__] cheesecake here you understand
you live like a doctor a doctor anyway
how about you [__] but I'm stoned
to the gills
well that's it you heard what I had to
tell you now go out there and do what
the [__] you gonna show up like one of
the three wise men till and by the way
those [__] with Jews were big
dicks they didn't give a [__] they
didn't give a [__] so you're showing up
like three wisemen that's what the Bible
don't tell you those three wise men were
some bad [__] the type of
people that came to look shut their
mouth there were three monkeys young Sam
made up oh yeah II got ya I'm most
important thing in the [__] world
anyway ain't o'clock tonight we got a
special church 499 what are your
favorites I hope you [__] swing by on
a tour watch it tomorrow morning beside
that that's it you got your [__]
mission for the day and I go out and
tell these [__] that you ain't
taking it no more you're doing it your
way like Sinatra and [__] 62 you
don't say I love you [__] without
you there's nothing let's do this
together
stay black I have a great [__] day
and I'll see you savages tonight 8
o'clock be there or be [__] sway
understand me boy they didn't come I
might tell a big noise sorry